und man sagt er sei man lebt nur einmal
lkr
herzlich willkommen zurück in der today
show letzter part mit den ort ab und
zwar part 64 sind wir glaube ich gerade
das heißt 16 folgen dann auch schon
vorher nach eingesteckt werden jetzt
genau 16 folgen oder interessenten
gewinnen
minecraft in bronze oder sowas in der
art ja gut thema mal wieder für diese
folgend ein bisschen kontrolliert habe
es geht das thema hat den ich soll
wieder raus schauen hier so nah bei
facebook muss einmal lesen
christian f lava schmeckt besser hund
oder katze ich dachte es ist was haltet
ihr davon
oliver speck blätter was haltet ihr
davon
das war so typisch bau mein haus mit
hoch glaube ich dass der farbe als park
oder von kehrt werde ich auf jeden fall
nicht herankommen nicht annähernd als
auch schon wieder die waffengesetze in
amerika darüber haben wir zum teil auch
schon geredet aber daher auch patricia
schaaf etwas zu gefragt weil sind echt
so viele fragen nicht zu krass was
würdet ihr im leben zurück setzen wenn
ihr könntet was würdet ihr zurücksetzen
ist nicht schlecht von nikita rezept ich
hoffe ich spreche diese namen richtig
aus nein war falsch danke zu man
eigentlich war man man man man weiß es
ja manchmal so spontan sage ich mal
welche sachen waren zurück setzen will
also wenn man jetzt zum beispiel ich
kann mich an nichts konkret erinnern
aber was ich zum beispiel weiß dass ich
das wort
es war damals so ich habe fußball
gespielt im garten mit einem freund und
wir haben so jalousien die per
knopfdruck fahren die hoch und runter
und die sind halt an den festen fenster
befestigt und beziehungsdramen den
fenstern und während spielen fußball in
einer schießt den ball wirklich so volle
kanne gegen diese jalousien und da war
so ein richtiger knick drinnen ist
ausgebrochen
und das war nicht mal ein toller schuss
aber die zeit einfach kaputt gegangen
und da denkt man sich zog
hätte ich das jetzt nicht geschossen und
borken ich jetzt die zeit zurückdrehen
so was glaube ich meinte meint die
allgemein so etwas größere ereignisse
der größte was man jetzt so aus der
heutigen sicht sich so denkt ach hätte
ich das einmal vor vier jahren anders
gemacht als ich bereits dass ich kein
jahr im ausland gemacht habe wer das
bereue ich auch also meine geschwister
machen das alle oder hab's gemacht und
ich so kann ich jetzt auch im studium
auslandssemester machen dann tun sie
jetzt nicht wiederholen das ja wenn ich
dann ein jahr weg das jetzt machen würde
dann müsste ich wiederholen darauf habe
ich bekommen aber jetzt im nachhinein
wenn es auch mein kleiner rudolphs grad
macht und meine schwester wird auch
machen wieder da
denke ich mir schon hätte ich das machen
soll ein kleiner bruder für 22 jährige
war so klein
jetzt soll ich darf jetzt da wird sich
kleiner bruder sein kleiner bruder
herzlich es gibt keine kleinen große
punkte also kleiner bruder nennt ok
passt alles gut
nein also ich glaube das war so mein
mentor ist die größte sache ein bisschen
bereue oder
noch fällt jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so
spontan ein
wo ich so sagen total schief gelaufen
weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll und
große fehler wäre die geburt gesagt das
könnte man so sagen
allein durchstehen verbraucht man schon
ein viertel der kalorien ihm ein
allgemein am tag verbraucht aber das ist
nebensache
von crafter volume 523
ich muss noch eine ahnung vielleicht
zeigen eigentlich würde ich glaube ich
gar nicht zurückdrehen also klar es gibt
sachen die scheiße sind oder scheiße
gelaufen sind das aber irgendwie ist das
doch alles so die erfahrung wird ich
meine es gibt nichts wofür zurück drehen
müsste weil wenn ich jetzt sage ja da
vor zwei jahren habe ich meine nintendo
ds oder so kaputt gemacht oder so wo ich
gar kein hatte nur ein beispiel aber und
man muss man ja dann alles noch mal
durchleben sage ich mal die zeit darauf
hätte ich erst mal überhaupt kein wort
wenn es gehen würde diese zeitreise
nochmal noch mal kind sein
ja wahrscheinlich nur wenn man das auch
wieder dann vor drehen könnte ja gerne
ändern und dann wieder vorträge bei der
heutigen also im bett macht folge hatten
ich hatte von anfang an 1
nachdem ich ein tier des perimeters als
der dinge wo ich mir sage also wo ich
mir jetzt wirklich noch sage boah hätte
ich das man damals nicht so gemacht und
wäre ich damals glücklicher gewesen oder
dann wäre das ganz anders gekommen alles
also das gibts echt zum paar sag ich mal
aber meistens wortmann auch nicht die
dinge die man gemacht hat sondern
meistens du hast meinen vor allem dann
die dinge die man eben nicht gemacht zum
beispiel leben man hat kein auslandsjahr
gemacht wenn man halt irgendwelche
erfahrungen halt nicht gemacht denkt
sich ach hätte ich es halt einfach doch
mal gemacht dass wir immer so gemacht
also aber scheiße dann hat man halt ich
erfahre man sagt ihr sollt man lebt nur
einmal
ok jollen oasis weg und zu aufs netbook
naja jedenfalls gibt es ja also das was
du jetzt meint man sollte eigentlich ein
tag nutzt blabla das soll ich vorhin
sagen aber was du meintest die meisten
sachen hat man wirklich nicht getan
stimmt aber bei mir geht's oft einige
dinge die ich gemacht habe wo ich mir
dann komplett mein jetziges leben sagt
man nicht mit versaut habe aber negativ
wo man sich nachteile mit geschaffen hat
zum beispiel damals in der schule das
ist jetzt in ganz ganz weit her der
griffe aber es basiert auf der realität
im wortlaut ist natürlich da ich laufe
durch trusted innen voll schönen oder da
ist ein dreieck bei mir wäre das über
ups da ist also ich laufe durch die
schule und alexa papierkügelchen und
läuft somit freuen her und ich krieg das
so rum und wir gucken das papier
glücklich in so was man halt so macht
man keine ahnung fährt sein und mit uns
das nicht mehr gemacht
mit 15 ist es total oldschool dass das
mainstream besonders macht jedenfalls
findet oldschool kabel dann soll eine
lehrerin meinte dann so ein auf oberteil
zu tun hat aber sie kann sich das
leisten
ein richtiger heck sondern dass wir so
ok hab ich mir genommen wollte seine
müll schmeißen guckt mich so um die
referendarin ist weg da habe ich beim
kumpel eine kapuze getan
volker gewinnen dann können die
referendarin und vorstellungen dann muss
der schulleitung und alles im blauen
jetzt habe ich bei der lehrerin total
verschätzt und die habe ich jetzt
die hast nicht
ja aber mit sowieso was kann ich
verstehen dass man sowas rückgängig
machen würde flankt so aber ist
natürlich auch eigentlich keine ist also
man ist ja schon
es macht ihnen jetzt wieder bei mir
drinnen gießen liegt ich komme mit
seiner haustür wieder an
also das sind halt irgendwie so sachen
dahinscheiden alter no drop
ist das dein ernst nicht ernsthaft tnt
platzieren oder halt jetzt müssen wir
gerade zu stehen
doch nicht bayer erklärte meyer als eine
kuh maske die ganze sehr häufig weiß
park den nord ab wenn du das machst
haben kein safe an der welt und alles
kaputt ganz vorsichtig da war es
einfacher verdienen
schlechte erfahrungen als eine brutale
sein das hat mir schon ein bisschen
hallo was auf der treppe spezialist wir
müssen vielmehr heißt das werk ich
gerade gelaufen da was der dna treffers
erst in vevey es ist ein webportal iams
kalte wasser blockbuster ob das ähnlich
ich mir ein comeback die brocken
ich habe mit einem mit zwei herzen
überlebt ich bin hier unter geflogenen
nicht los von 100 herzen auf zwei also
von zehn jahren 100 herzen als männer
doch zwei runter doch ihr tun demnächst
wenn du nix kaputt machst kannst du das
war richtig episch
ich laufe hier ist irgendwie ein loch
und ich falle in das loch ein und fall
herunter und hat noch ein herz als zwei
herzen glaube ich ungefähr
juli um irina dähne kommt zurück
er zündet sich selber ab unterdessen
erst bei deinem haus erst mit einem haus
will ihn nicht mehr das war heute nicht
so lange nix macht werde ich noch nicht
töten aber sobald er immer vor allem aus
toleriert wasserkarte von steinbach ja
du musst reingreifen im zweifel ja ein
zweifel dass ich diese bösen videospiele
dieses spiel glaube ich ist ich würde
sagen mit verbrenner für videospiele
okay wenn ich brenne auch er hat mich
geschlagen
das ist darauf angelegt ich hab' ich
habt ihr die wahl gelassen den erfolg
kommt von oben besser bei deinem
hauptbahn unserem in meinem haus unten
oder wo unten eisbahn amerika mich kam
ich komme bürgerwehr diener ist da
er setzt den kompletten wald in flammen
alter der waldbahn abreise baldig nein
es ist nicht gut
er fasst sich ein denkmal sein ich habe
sich geschockt als er den kompletten
komplette bald kaputt
dann schaffen wir doch nur der baum
brennt müssen dass er alle 17 weiter an
anderen bäumen dran sind die muss so am
besten alle habt auch erwarte ich hab
doch jetzt alle kopf an kopf
da sprechen wir die welt dreht immer
wieder springt die verhältnisse schon
wieder was an erfolg ausmachen sagt
kainz weg gegeben den tod
bei uns zu hause nicht wieder
ich will das nicht das war ja kein
feuerzeug
ich gebe ihm ein feuerzeug aber als der
frieden hier hier willst dich töten
ich freue mich aber auch 16 er hat 16
flint gar nicht schlecht als lukas
könnte was werden wenn der nächste gast
nicht so ein verrücktes keines geben
oder ob ich denke mal sein ganzes haus
brennen freue mich aber jetzt dass nur
seine farben hier denkt auch dein haus
brennt es brennt wirklich wirklich ist
aber nicht schlecht geworden aber es hat
gar keine tür dass das gefäß soja wir
setzten uns ausgehen und das bewerten
oder kommst mit das ist sich werte ja
egal du musst uns gem wer anstatt fertig
auszubauen
andere häuser anzündete er muss mit den
konsequenzen die anderen eine grube
gräbt der kategorie bereits
was haben denn hier oben ist wasser zu
sehen sein haus an
verliert gegen sony wer also wir schauen
uns das haus von außen an
von außen sieht man da nicht so viel
halt nur so ein feuer feuer feuer feuer
erinnert mich an den bunker von der
direkte nachbar im paket zusammen so von
außen von ihnen müssen uns das noch mal
anschauen
alle hoch ist noch dieselbe
gesichtsfarbe wie die zombies ich glaube
das einfach nicht aggressiv geht auf
alles und jeden
lasst das mal betrieben aber in muss man
sagen geschmackvoll eingerichtet oder
das sieht nicht schlecht aus eigentlich
und dazu geordnetes angesammelt aussagen
danke danke
das habe ich 5 er will uns nur bestechen
das war jedenfalls eine option
kastrierte kater schon danke dass du
dabei was alle folgen könnt ihr
natürlich auch auf seinem kanal
anschauen welches angebunden dass wir
dieses diese folge dann mal wieder und
ihr könnt uns er weiterhin themen in die
kommentare schreiben
reisegäste die eventuell sehen wollt ihr
noch nicht da waren beziehungsweise
änderungen wie in der ersten folge
dieser aufnahme gesagt haben ab jetzt
werden wir immer bei aufnahme beginnen
bei facebook ein poster phasen hier
schreibt uns kommentare und dann könnt
ihr das da schreiben und dann ist die
chance aus der kuss dass wir einen
kommentar von mir facebook bitte nicht
sein dass er kein facebook habt oder so
auf die facebook-seite ihr müsst ihr gar
nicht leiden genau ihr könnt auch
einfach selbst heute noch nicht darauf
gehen und kommen die eigentlich seit
facebook account aber auch wenn ihr bei
facebook könnt ihr natürlich auch
falsche daten angeben und mache
natürlich immer mehr aber die clowns
fand ich kann eure daten die verkaufen
eure da die machen die stirn euer leben
also ist mindestens und alles und so da
damit sollte das den autos etwas scheiße
er hats wir in diamant schwert getötet
alles läuft dabei sein durfte server
wenn ihr mehr von ihm noch sehen wollt
dann schaut er am besten kann wobei der
macht zum beispiel pvp minecraft sachen
weil ich ein update vorstellung bot
reviews ich weiß nicht was du ja nur pvp
was machst du alles okay er macht pvp
und sub und das könnte ich bei jemand
bauen ansonsten ist er vielleicht auch
mal bei ist ja sonst ist auch bei
manchmal bei kraft dazu habe ich auch
mein land einmal weil ich eigentlich mit
kathi machen wollte gerade und das ist
einfach ein video gesehen aber ihr
werdet ihn finden
ich dachte so erwert gut im pvp
hindernisse sofort verdächtig war einen
tag schlecht drauf aber sonst bei jedem
event immer gewinnst du immer immer
immer den monster hunter folge
depression
ja weil wir immer getötet foto w
den ofen oder ob andere luca high five
nur ohne schwert weil ich erwarte ich
muss hier ja etwas der 232 wir ihn heute
haben wir jetzt den namen ist nur noch
zur richtigen zeit kommt noch mal hier
dabei mit trolley und mit mit 36 dieser
weise 30 21 so normal normal doch ich
habe gar kein leben und sehen
ich bin einfach sagen die folge wird
viel zu lang sehen uns dann das nächste
mal wieder wie die zuschauer bleibt uns
weiter die treue hielt und 22
selbständige welle bleibst du nicht mal
macht